good morning believe nation today's
message is define your expectations over
to you John Mayer I wake up every mood
miss Renslow TV go number one thing you
have to do before you set out on any
other goal or any other course is to
define your expectations number one
thing on the outset of every single
project record tour define your
expectations everyone in this room wants
to make it but I question how you would
recognize making it what is making it
well what do you want to be who you and
here wants a record deal would it be
nice to everybody nice to have a record
deal ride we want to record to you okay
well what does a record deal look like
how.what is making it look like do you
want to sell a million copies two
million copies well okay let's say
selling two million copies is like
selling town 10 million copies ten years
ago so let's say you say to yourself my
expectation is that I want to be an
artist and I wanted to put records out
and i want to sell millions of copies if
that's their expectation great then you
sort of skip straight to another
questionnaire you know okay if you
answered yes to do I want to be a pop
star do I want to make music for as many
people as possible now you have to sort
of change your game to fit the
expectation I think a lot of people
under sell themselves I think a lot of
people don't really know what success
looks like and then they never actually
go out and accomplish it I think a lot
of people want to start a business they
wanted to become this huge success
because that's not define what that
looks like they never actually get there
i'm currently mentoring an entrepreneur
taking over a business and I've hired
operations guy to run it for me because
I'm busy doing this and I'm training him
to be an entrepreneur and think like an
entrepreneur and he has a short-term
goal of turning it into a million-dollar
business and he doesn't actually fully
believe yet that it's a million-dollar
business that it can be because he's
thinking it's never been a
million-dollar business so why would it
ever be
come a million-dollar business and right
there that kind of thinking is what I
need to stomp out by my 101 training and
coaching with him that's what I need to
push away because as long as he believes
that it's never going to be a
million-dollar business then it never
will be and I want him to start thinking
how do we get this to be a 10 million
dollar business 100 million dollar
business because when you start thinking
like that it alters not just your
confidence but the actions that you take
today right to build a 10 million dollar
business versus a half a million dollar
business you have to think act and
communicate differently I look at my
business I want to be able to help a
billion entrepreneurs that's my goal
that means to accomplish that big goal I
have to stop doing certain things today
and start doing other ones everything I
try to do now is add scale right I'm not
trying to help people one on one on one
on one because that will take a long way
to get to a billion right I do think
that scale through the youtube channel
through my book through my radio show
through a lot of different opportunities
seminars webinars social media
everything I do is at scale because it
helps me accomplish my goal of hitting
that billion entrepreneur mark so when
you have clarity and you know what you
want to do and you challenge yourself to
think a little bit bigger and you know
what that looks like then it alters your
confidence it alters how you inspire
your team and alters the actions that
you take today to help you move forward
and reach your goal so my question that
a few guys today is are your
expectations too low leave it in the
comments below and I'm going to join in
the discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and i'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
expresso give me go